Hello Freak bitches.
I got a question for you man.
Okay.
So,
um,
I've been a fan of you for a long time,
right?
So what,
thank you,
I appreciate it.
I appreciate you.
Appreciate you.
What uh,
what,
uh,
made you made the switch from like being a moon landing denier to like,
you're fucking crazy if we didn't,
if you don't know,
I don't think we're crazy.
No,
this is,
this is my,
my take on it.
Absolutely.
I don't know enough about astrophysics,
about space travel,
about the science that's,
you know,
the,
the work that's been done about how to get a rock a rocket to the moon and back
definitely don't know enough.
It's rocket science.
And I've looked at a lot of very compelling documentaries that explain why they
think it was hoaxed and they'll show you some footage and you can look at some
of the footage and it looks fake as fuck.
There's some footage that to me looks really doctored.
There's some Dell yet to this day.
Some guy would,
when you ever seen ones where it looks like they're on wire.
So to astronauts on,
on wires I have,
there's somewhere,
there's a video where they look at their own trampoline and they're bouncing
around on trampolines.
The physics are different in different videos.
This is where it gets weird.
Like the physics are different from the Apollo 11 moon landing.
We see him waddle around on the surface of the moon.
They moving at like half speed and then you see them in other ones like the one
where they bounce around the air,
you're like,
well,
they're moving different.
They're in the same thing,
but it looks different.
The first one was very grainy.
They showed it on a projection screen,
right?
It's,
there's,
there's uh,
there's a couple different possibilities.
One possibility is it just looks weird because it's on the moon and your brain
is trying to interpret it and your brain's going,
well that's fake because you don't really understand with one six or as gravity
really does to a body of it.
That's one possibility.
Another possibility,
which has been shown to be true is that some of the stuff that they passed off
as being legitimate photographs of space travel was actually test runs where
they blacked out the background and pretended that they were in space.
And there's one really clear example of this is Michael Collins.
Michael Collins,
who was a guy who was a board Apollo 11,
right?
And Gemini 15.
There's a photo of him,
uh,
in uh,
the middle of a sea of what does it,
when they walk around outside the space water,
it's called spacebar.
Why does that seem like a bad word?
It's like spacewalk.
Like if it doesn't seem like that's the official title I middle of a space walk
is probably something more,
a little more syllables.
Yeah,
something slicker.
Anyway,
so he's doing the space walk and he's got this harness on,
he's holding onto this like thing and it was apparently it just an image that
had already been published of him in a training exercise and they blacked out
the background and flipped the picture upside down.
That's the joint right there.
So same exact photo.
Same exact photo.
I mean people have lined it up and switched it over.
It's the same photo.
It's just been edited.
So I'm one on the left was them practicing how to use these.
I don't get sad.
The harness is some sort of a thing that he's hanging onto it.
I guess it moves them around a little bit.
Right?
They were trying to practice it on the left and the right.
They just pass it off.
But those are publicity photos.
Right?
All right,
so you've got to go.
Well,
okay,
well who approves a publicity pose?
It could easily be just some idiot who works in the publicity department who
didn't marketing and who didn't think they had enough photos from the moon that
we're good of spacewalks it's probably insanely difficult to take a spacewalk
photo.
So does that mean that they faked the moon landing?
No,
but it means that people fake things.
So you've got to throw it like gotta be really objective and looking at that.
Okay.
So people say fake things.
They definitely filmed a lot of the,
um,
the training exercises that they did of the moon landing.
It filmed a lot of shit.
They definitely did.
If that is already been proven that they took this fake photograph and they
tried to pass it off as a real space.
Why?
It's entirely possible that some of the stuff that they filmed,
they made out to look like they were on the moon when they were not.
But does that mean they didn't go to the moon?
No,
it doesn't.
And so when I was saying it proves that they didn't go to the moon.
I,
my critique of myself is that I didn't look at it objectively because I wanted
one conclusion to be true and I wanted that conclusion to be that the moon
landing was fake.
So I looked at it and I was,
and I was saying to myself,
okay,
did I come to this conclusion?
Because there's a lot of evidence that shows it to be fake or have I seen a lot
of evidence that looks fake?
And does that mean that they didn't go to the moon?
No,
it doesn't.
There's,
there's a bunch of different possibilities.
There's a ton of different possibilities.
There's also the possibility that whatever photographs they took can get
severely damaged in the radiation of space.
And it was really difficult to do.
Right.
That's possible too.
And that they,
they decided somehow or another that they were going to pass off these,
that they actually did go and they decided they're going to pass off some of
these fake videos.
So there's a bunch of possibilities.
The possibility that it looks fake because I'm dumb and because I don't
understand anything about the physics of one six earth's gravity and it just
looks weird because it's shitty film.
It's 1969 that's possibility number one.
Number two is they fake some things or number three is they,
they didn't really have good footage because like you couldn't take film through
the airport.
Remember that?
Like people would go through those right.
Radar detectors and you're filming get jacked and they wouldn't wear it
responsibly.
You didn't have the film.
But I know people that might,
you know,
I have friends that are photographers and um,
my uncle is a photographer and he would tell me,
you can't send the,
the film,
like if you have like you've take a roll of film and the awesome picture didn't
get it through.
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck they did,
but I know that some film has been damaged or maybe it's an urban myth.
Maybe they would find out of film got damaged by a,
those radar things at the airport,
x rays,
x rays.
We could appreciate the mindset though of looking at your opinion objective,
Lee,
and saying,
am I tripping?
It's looking at the facts and say,
I'm just not really sure.
I think that's the problem with people today,
people in period is that they're afraid to say,
I don't know.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They're super afraid.
It's like,
to me,
ignorance is such a gift.
Like it just gives you an opportunity to learn some shit if you're humble
enough.
Like,
don't assume you know,
even though she had,
I felt like,
I know I still feel like,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well that seems,
you have a very healthy ego for a big young fucking super athlete.
It's fucking,
that's fucking football man.
Like,
no,
but I'm saying ego is very healthy.
You have a really good way of looking at things.
I think that's,
that's the right way to be mad at you can't be married to was to like ideas and
opinions like that because they're not you.
But we think that they are,
they're like an extension of us.
So we want to win these arguments.
Yeah.
We want to be right.
I think it gets real scary when you want to be right.
And then you're willing to ignore evidence that might show that you're wrong.
Right.
That's how I felt about myself.
And by the way,
if you wanted to,
if you wanted a conspiracy,
that's a good one.
That seems like it might be possible.
The Moon landings,
one of the best ones,
and this is why it's so attractive between 1969 in 1973 he's still on the fence
about this,
Huh?
No,
no.
I'm not at all.
I'm on the,
I don't know shit fence.
That's where I live.
All right,
but between that facts on this side,
I'm with you though.
They sent,
I think it was seven missions.
Six of them were successful.
The only one that wasn't successful as Apollo 13 right.
They sent these fucking people around the moon,
250,000 plus miles out there and back,
but ever since then all they've been able to do is get people into near Earth
orbit ever since then,
like the highest anyone's ever gone,
I think it's 400 miles.
So they went from 260,000 miles all the way to the moon and back to 400 miles.
Everything is like inside and they've never gone through the mat of Van Allen
radiation belts.
It never got into deep space and return.
They haven't done that since 1960 1973 I thought and I could be wrong,
but I thought it was because of like funding could be like,
cause you know,
we know lacmas got funds.
Show me,
show me how that makes sense.
You don't want to fund space travel.
You want to fund that fucking acrylic box or box and edited by the way.
That's perfect.
It is great.
I don't,
I don't think that I know whether or not we went to the moon,
but I'm telling you that if you wanted a juicy conspiracy I'm looking to get
excited about,
I was looking into,
it's the best one to get excited about.
I lost all the data.
I see.
Cause like I see like,
you know,
you go down to Youtube Wormhole,
you started watching Barry Sanders highlight and then I'm looking at JFK,
me and Michael Jackson or some shit.
But like I,
I just don't see what the motive would be like what is the fucking mode like
what Cold War.
Um,
first of all,
we wanted to beat the Russians because we were in a race to see who can get to
the,
to the moon.
And here's one of the things that we do know for a fact.
The Russians faked a bunch of shit.
They fixing bunch of footage.
Yeah.
Yuri Gagarin,
who was the first man in space,
they had a video,
might be an expert on this man.
But there,
well,
I studied this,
I debated a guy who was a really nice guy,
but,
um,
Phil plait,
who's a bat astronomer,
bad astronomer.com.
Okay.
And um,
he,
he was a lot of things he wasn't willing to admit though that were unfortunate
because maybe he could have convinced me more if he was,
and one of the big ones was that Warner von Braun was a Nazi.
We,
they hired a bunch of Nazis to,
to run the space program.
It was called operation paperclip and what operation paperclip was when they
took a bunch of Nazi scientists and relocated them to the United States.
We lost some of them to Russia,
the Russia scooped up song of them.
But when we ended the World War Two and Nazi Germany collapsed,
we went in and took the scientists,
will Wernher von Braun was the head of a rocket factory in,
in,
um,
in Berlin where these,
to hang the five slowest Jews in front of the rocket factory for all the other
workers to see Warner von Braun,
the Simon Wiesenthal Center said,
if a von Braun was alive today,
he'd be punished for crimes against humanity.
This is news.
No,
Wernher von Braun was a straight up Nazi and this guy was not willing to admit
that.
Right.
You know,
it's like,
well,
you know,
just because someone's in Germany.
No,
no,
no.
He was a Nazi.
He's,
you know,
he was a Nazi.
Were there any actually killed anybody?
Maybe he had to be a Nazi.
I mean,
we're not saying that,
look,
if you're fucked and you're in this neighborhood and that it overcomes the
entire neighborhood,
you want to keep your family alive.
So you put that thing on your,
uh,
your jacket sleeve.
You put that swastika on and you see high like everybody else.
Maybe you're not really a Nazi ideologically.
Maybe you're not a Nazi in your heart.
Maybe just trying to stay alive.
That's entirely possible too.
But he was a Nazi.
He was a fucking Nazi,
and they had slaves that were running rocket factories in Berlin where they were
figuring out how to make rockets.
I said,
Brandon,
I gotta I gotta I need to,
yeah,
operation paperclip,
Cold War President Truman authorized operation paperclip in August of 1945 the
US army had secretly admitted 88 German scientists and engineers to help a
development of rocket technology,
including Wernher von Braun,
Arthur Rudolph,
and her butt to struggled her Berkus,
her Bertus,
Hugh Bertis,
we us.
That's a great name.
It's not a great name.
Bring that back.
Burn.
If you have a fucking stud.
Kid is like,
when it's strongest man in the world.
His name is [inaudible] my son.
Do you purchase?
Fuck that.
I was named after a Nazi.
So there,
there was like something in the debate that guy was not willing to admit,
which made me even more skeptical that he was right about the other stuff.
The other thing was that they like and moon rocks that they've collected from
the moon if turned out to not really be moon rocks like a bunch of them for sure
have been tested by scientists and they found that these Brock's or from another
planet,
but there was,
there was a rock that they gave to whoever's the head of Holland and it was
personally given with a plaque by Neil Armstrong,
buzz Aldrin and Michael Collins and it turned out to be petrified wood moon rock
given to Holland by Neil Armstrong and buzz Aldrin is fake.
It's a moon rock given to the Dutch prime minister by the Apollo 11 astronauts
in 1969 turned out to be a fake.
So they were giving people pieces of petrified wood say,
and this is for you.
We went to the moon.
God bless America,
308,000 euros.
Now there's,
there's a bunch of possibilities.
Okay,
let's just be honest about this because this story is from 2009 it's entirely
possible that between 1969 that,
well this is,
there's multiple sources.
That's the telegraph.
That's a legit news.
You got to trace to source for sure.
But I'm saying is that it's entirely possible that someone stole that Moon Rock
and replaced with that.
That's possible.
Or it's possible.
They just had some fake rocks.
Here's the thing,
Bill Clinton had a fucking,
he had a quote in his book in one of his books,
um,
I think his book is called my life.
And he had a quote about the moon landing and a story about him having this
conversation with a carpenter and at this carpenter said that he didn't believe
the moon landing.
He goes,
them television fellers they can make anything look real.
And he said,
this is a quote and Bill Clinton's fucking book.
He said,
back then I thought that guy was a quack,
but after our crank,
whenever,
crazy person.
But after eight years in the White House,
I was wondering if he wasn't ahead of his time.
Oh Wow.
This is a guy that was the fucking president of the United States and he's
talking specifically about an old carpenter telling him the moon landing was
fake.
And then he says,
I wondered after eight years in the White House,
if that guy wasn't ahead of his time,
causation,
correlation.
Yeah,
no,
look,
could be bullshit.
Yeah.
Could be bullshit.
100%.
It could be just a good story.
I think that's the thing about conspiracy theories.
It's like they lead you on all these dead end Chase's Oh yeah.
So the long answer of your question,
that's,
that's where I stood on this whole moon landing thing.
That's why I came around to thinking in a different way that was way too
convinced that I was right.
Right.
I'm like,
I'm convinced I was right,
but it's fucking real low levels of understanding of any of the science of this
stuff.
That's the problem is as a society,
we're so scientifically illiterate,
you know,
and that,
that,
that causes so much room for speculation and you're kind of,
um,
you kind of a prisoner of,
of,
of people who are masters of their crafts,
you're kind of a prisoner to their quote unquote agenda.
I don't want to put that that bad of a term on it,
but you're kind of prisoner of that because we don't have,
we don't have any,
any,
any choice.
But to take there a word for or to pursue it yourself.
Right.
To learn about what they're talking about yourself,
you know,
if they're right or not.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's absolutely the case,
right.
Cause you know,
that's the case in almost everything else.
Okay.